well so it congratulations tell you guys  the other filmmakers here you guys are  amazing and this week has been a lot  more much more memorable experience than  I would ever have imagined just by  getting to know you guys so I'd like to  start by saying thanks to everyone who's  given me help and feedback on my film  along the way not just the people of my  credits my friends and family you guys  have always been great support whenever  I'm stressed out people from SVA all my  classmates they're awesome people hope  to see them again soon and of course  thank you mom and dad for putting me  through school of course but also for  always being adamant about giving my  brother and me the support and the  resources to learn the things that  interest us and always been passionate  about you know learning and teaching I I  feel privileged i was able to grow up in  a house full of books to feed my  imagination so thank you mom and dad and  thank you everyone